[Applause]
can i let you guys in on a little secret
i really want our show to be a safe
space
a place where we can leave our
differences at the door and just
feel welcomed this is an all ages party
and everyone's invited
our dream with this show is to find
common ground or as i call it
the pretty little middle pretty little
middle
and no matter what your beliefs or
values are today i wanted to celebrate
ruth bader ginsburg
and i found all these things as i dove
in
this weekend i read everything i read
her book
i watched her documentary i immersed
myself
in her life her marriage was just
so amazing the way her and her husband
supported each other
when he was sick she took care of him
and did his homework when
she was sick he took care of her they
were so supportive of each other
and she just had this incredible
strategy about the long game and
she had this ability to be confident and
comfortable in silences she talks about
in her book i learned something i'm
horrible at that her attitude about
anger pushing people away that
i learned from too you know she was a
law student
and a judge and a lawyer and she has
this incredible legacy
and now she inspires a whole new
generation
and i kind of thought after being able
to ace
any test you could give me on rbg
what could i talk about on this show
about her you know
we're all seeing everything all weekend
and
i was compelled to talk about
how she found common ground with all her
colleagues on the supreme court
especially when they didn't agree and
they didn't argue small fights
it wasn't like did you see the game last
night or
i swear to god if you park your car near
my driveway again
or what's better the french fryer tater
tot like they are
confronting the biggest issues and
things are all easy when we agree but
when we don't can we find the way in
where we might come together
i know i am naive in thinking this but
she was able to maintain friendships
with
colleagues who she disagreed with and it
just moved me so much
and i thought you know what i want to
shine a light on this
and i found the lyrics to this opera
that were written for her
and anton and scalia and they were like
on opposite sides of the spectrum
and they still found a way to have an
incredible friendship
and when i read the words to this i had
an incredible revelation
that even though they felt like they
represented the divides and attitudes
and values they could still work
together
and it gave me so much hope
[Music]
you